Oh next week we're gonna be doing our
show from New York City that's gonna be
a lot of fun we have some great guests
lined up including louis c.k is going to
join us Tracy Morgan Ryan Reynolds and
the entire thing is made possible by our
friends at Pepsi zero sugar so oh oh
yeah that is so awesome I'm sorry that's
one of our cameramen Tony Tony what's up
so you're going to New York next week
coding yeah that's right that's yes hey
Conan guess where I'm from I'm gonna
guess New York yeah that's that's that's
great Tony
the Windy Apple excuse me
the Windy Apple that's one of the
nicknames for New York I know a lot
about New York yeah Tony I'm pretty sure
it's the Big Apple not the Windy Apple
says you I grew up there I know
everything about the city in which
you'll typically get zero sleep I know
Tony it's called the city that never
sleeps
Tony Tony where exactly in New York City
did you grow up right on the corner of
14th Avenue and 309 Street you know next
to the International Museum of snakes
and boats okay
tony has zero idea what he's talking
about yeah I may have zero idea what I'm
talking about
but I know what's refreshing Pepsi zero
sugar okay Tony was this whole thing
just a Pepsi zero sugar product
integration that you just did you've got
that right now excuse me while I
integrate this delicious soft drink into
my face yeah okay well as I said we're
gonna be doing yeah okay all right like
I said we'll be doing our show in New
York City all next week all right well
good luck Conan it's like they say if
you can make it there hooray for you
that's a real accomplishment
nice
Eliza works here stick around
you
you